The Adventures of Sharkboy and Lavagirl in
3-D was essential viewing for many kids in
2005.
The kid-friendly adventure film directed by
Robert Rodriguez follows the titular adolescent
superheroes as they come to life from the
imagination of a 10-year-old, bringing him
to their planet to protect it from aliens.
Children who watched the movie in theaters
have likely been wondering what the heroes
have been up to for the last 15 years.
Now, they're about to get their answer, thanks
to Rodriguez's upcoming film We Can Be Heroes.
The soon-to-be-released Netflix film primarily
focuses on a slightly different group of superheroes.
The likes of Marcus Moreno, played by Pedro
Pascal, and Christian Slater’s Tech-No,
make up a superhero collective known as the
Heroics.
One day, the heroes are captured, and it's
up to their super-powered children to step
up and save the day.
In the midst of this, Sharkboy and Lavagirl
return — now as adult heroes, who are married
and have a daughter of their own.
Audiences with a penchant for thrillers may
actually recognize Sharkboy and Lavagirl's
daughter, who's known as Guppy; the actress
who plays her is Vivien Lyra Blair, who portrayed
Girl in the apocalyptic Netflix hit Bird Box.
She'll be joined by the original Sharkgirl
star Taylor Dooley, who's returning as the
pink-haired heroine.
To the disappointment of many, Taylor Lautner
will not be reprising his role for We Can
Be Heroes, but based on photos released by
Netflix on Twitter, Sharkboy will still be
there, just played by J.J.
Dashnaw this time around.
And now, Sharkboy has the power to transform
into a giant glass shark.
Talk about a glow-up!
No word yet on whether Sharkboy goes by Sharkman
these days, but regardless, fans are hyped
to see the return of the two colorful characters.
News of We Can Be Heroes coming to Netflix
has been out for a while now, as the project
was first announced in August 2019.
Details were kept under wraps, but in a mid-November
2020 interview with Entertainment Weekly,
Rodriguez teased that We Can Be Heroes could
be considered a spiritual sequel of sorts
to The Adventures of Sharkboy and Lavagirl
in 3-D.
Just a few days later, Netflix confirmed that
We Can Be Heroes will indeed involve the two
vibrant heroes from many people's childhoods.
While Sharkboy and Lavagirl won't be front
and center for the film, they'll be around
and have plenty of opportunities to show off
their respective powers.
Hopefully their roles are more than just cameos,
because fans are ecstatic to relive their
youth.
Twitter user @antoinedaboi wrote,
"HOLY S--- 'WE CAN BE HEROES' WILL BE OUT
ON NEW YEARS...
UGH CHILDHOOD IS COMING BACK."
Another fan tweeted,
"SHARKBOY AND LAVAGIRL IS BACK HOLY S--- MY
CHILDHOOD DREAMS ARE COMING TRUE."
Netflix has a ton of content coming out in
the next couple of months, including a slew
of Christmas movies, but it's still understandable
if the only thing you can focus on now is
when you'll be able to watch a bunch of precocious
kids fight bad guys.
For some, We Can Be Heroes takes precedence
over Oscar contenders, as evidenced by @TheDaddyKuma
saying,
"I can't see how anyone can care about Mank
when We Can Be Heroes is imminent, I just
simply don't get it."
User @JabsSkyWalker agreed with that take,
tweeting,
"The Sharkboy and Lavagirl sequel will be
an Oscar nominated masterpiece."
One Twitter user had a more tempered reaction
to the news, though they did admit that they're,
quote, "super excited" to watch We Can Be
Heroes when it hits Netflix on January 1.
They wrote,
"I absolutely adored Sharkboy and Lavagirl.
[...] I'm not expecting a cinematic masterpiece
or anything, but who knows.
Maybe I'll be pleasantly surprised."
Though Sharkboy and Lavagirl's presence is
enough to get anyone excited, it's still unclear
what the extent of their roles will be.
However, Twitter user @Edu_Alvarez1188 has
but one simple request,
"We better get the Sharkboy Dream song [remastered]."
Going into 2021, that's probably all that
anyone really wants, at this point.
And many are hoping that We Can Be Heroes
will be the saving grace of 2021.
Twitterer @xenoworth wrote,
"if 2021 isn't good then at least we'll always
have the sharkboy and lavagirl sequel to fall
back on."
While @VelocityPD_ wisely tweeted,
"if 2021 is starting with a sequel to Sharkboy
and Lavagirl then we might expect a good year."
You'll be able to see Sharkboy, Lavagirl,
and a bunch of new characters — like Priyanka
Chopra Jonas' Ms. Granada — suit up for
action when We Can Be Heroes drops on Netflix
on January 1, 2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows and movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.